hey guys today is the 26th of January my
name is Jeff and here's what master in
gaming to them after a slew of lakes
Activision has now officially revealed
that Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
mutants in Manhattan is coming the game
is being developed by Bayonetta and
transformers devastation studio platinum
games a trailer narrated by the series's
antagonist shredder was released today
it shows off of birds i look at
manhattan a bunch of fearsome Foot Clan
foes and of course our turtle heroes in
all their bandana wearing ninja weapon
wielding glory we also got a glimpse of
iconic characters including bebop
Rocksteady and this cyborg shark I'm a
gun the game will be out this summer on
ps4 ps3 360 xbox one and feasting be
sure to roll in and pick up your free
halo 5 content today because the next
update is out now the newest free
expansion infinity armory will provide
you with the riptide and urban maps as
well as brand new wrecks that offer up a
halo to air a battle rifle variants on
the carbon rifle and a new Achilles
armor set there's also a couple of new
assassinations to pick up 343 industries
have promised to give you a bunch more
free stuff for Halo 5 right up until
this summer finally EA have dropped the
details for new content set to arrive in
star wars battlefront this month the
shooter will get free multiplayer modes
for the Tatooine map as well as hot
themed outfits for Luke Skywalker and
Han Solo the content pack which deploys
on Wednesday will also make various
gameplay and balance tweaks introduces
face for daily challenges and community
events and allow players to create
private matches yay also reveals a menu
Tatooine survival map will be released
for free in march along with a new Endor
multiplayer map meanwhile the fabric
update is set to offer up a new survival
mission on half and a new half the
multiplayer
additionally EA said that by februari
all multiplayer maps which support walk
result and supremacy modes will also
support turning point if you've walked
out for the fifty dollar deal t paso
don't just maybe cuz great stuff is
headed your way to EA revealed that for
premium expansions are scheduled for
release between March of this year and
early 2017 these will take place in the
outer rim and inside Jabba the Hutt's
palace on Tatooine within the cloud city
of Bespin and on the Death Star
respectively the fourth expansion is yet
to be announced let me know down in that
comment section if you're still playing
star wars battlefront and the work
content edition you're most excited for
you can add a game spot we've got throws
on the divisions closed beta and this
week what's fields of gold that is
everything I have be today with do join
me against in time tomorrow for a bunch
more news I will catch it